et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec ali benouari président du parti
algérien nida el watan bonjour et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur rt
france peut-on parler d'un geste
d'apaisement de la part du président
algérien
oui et simplement la libération de
l'opinion même si le mode et du dock
union des clubs français est à saluer et
puis c'était d'ailleurs l'une des
revendications de la quasi totalité de
la classe politique ou de ce qui tient
lieu de classe politique
donc c'est inciter à préalable et je
pense que le président a bien compris
que rien ne peut se faire tant que des
détenus d'opinion sans sens en garde et
or jugement ou après des jugements
expéditifs
ces annonces seront tels toutefois
suffisante je rappelle que lundi les
algériens vont célébrer le deuxième
anniversaire du irak avec de nombreux
vous appellent à manifester
oui il faut d'abord souligner le
contexte dans lequel intervient sept
discours du président teboul c'est un
contexte marqué par la plus grave crise
écologique plus l'algérie ait connu
depuis son indépendance c'est une crise
à la fois politique économique sociale
morale générationnel et tout cela sur
fond de crise sanitaire ou et les défis
sont immenses pour le prochain
gouvernement
donc je ne sais pas quelle sera sa
composante
quelles seront ses missions mais en tout
cas que de gens peu d'observateurs
pensent que un gouvernement quel qu'il
soit nous met dans ces conditions là que
résoudre les problèmes qui se posent aux
azuréens enfin il est parmi les annonces
il ya la dissolution du parlement aussi
que les algériens réclament à cor et à
cri depuis très longtemps moi même je le
réclame et quand j'étais candidat aux
élections présidentielles en 2013
première mesure je disais dissolution du
parlement ce n'est pas le port le
parlement des algériens donc cette
dissolution était attendu les élections
législatives aussi c'est bien sûr ça va
avec
bref
en tout considérer voyez vous le 7
ces mesures qui sont parmi les autres
mesures qui a créé à lens et qui découle
de la nouvelle constitution qui a été
adoptée le 1er novembre et qui a été
boycotté massivement
enfin il ya beaucoup de dispositions
dans le discours du président qui qui
découle de cette nouvelle constitution
maintenant on peut voir cette présidence
thème bonne qui est décrié n'est ce pas
c'est le moins que l'on puisse dire
comme à la fois ou bien comme une une
présidence d'arrière-garde est là pour
perpétuer bien sûr l'ancien système et
là le nul doute que les manifestations
reprendront et probablement avec de plus
en plus de violence ce que personne en
tout cas qui montre que le président
algérien souhaite rompre avec l'ancien
système dénoncé par ce mouvement induit
irak
deux ans après donc cette révolte
populaire c'est un mouvement qui semble
toujours tenir avec la preuve de cet
anniversaire et il tient malgré les
arrestations les condamnations malgré la
crise sanitaire qu'est ce que je voulais
je préside on peut la voir donc avéré
plutôt comme une présidence de train une
présence de 30
c'est tout simplement que le processus
de transition l'a eu hier vous 6
réclamés soit réalisé
sous sa conduite donc cela est quelque
chose qui est possible donc le
redressement on aurait un gouvernement
transit de transition ou transitionnelle
là on aurait une des institutions
transitionnelle qui fonctionnerait
jusqu'à l'adoption d'une nouvelle
constitution et qui ma foi
cette politique de petits pas et ma ma
préférence personnellement je la préfère
hors évolution chaotique où on veut en
eau
toutes les institutions entendre où on
sait pas trop dans quelle direction
aller on a vu en tunisie on l'a vu hélas
encore la tunisie est le cas le plus
le moins problématique enfin on l'a vu
dans d'autres pays
donc moi je vois plutôt la présence de
têtes brunes comme une présidence de
transition
évidemment il lui appartient à lui de
faire que le peuple soit écouté que
toutes les revendications du perak qui
je le rappelle de le départ du système
un état civil est habilité à etc
cela est théoriquement possible cette
politique de petits pas est possible et
puis ça permet aussi la dissolution de
l'assemblée que qui est absolument à la
chronique puisqu'il a été désigné je
dirais même pas élus de l'époque de
bouteflika qui lui-même est parti
devrait pouvoir laisser place à de
nouveaux partis de nouveaux acteurs et
le président a parlé d'ailleurs je crois
de nouveaux acteurs politiques
on ne peut pas le pays ne peut pas
continuer à fonctionner avec des acteurs
politiques qui ne représente finalement
à grand chose
je dis toujours qui tient lieu de classe
politique
donc il faut de nouveaux acteurs
politiques il faut assouplir et c'est
ces deux prises dans la part des la
constitution le prévoit cette nouvelle
constitution dont je rappelle qu'elle
est qu'à décriée par tous le moment ça
elle est là et on peut faire avec
notamment favoriser l'émergence d'une
nouvelle classe politique du tissu
associatif indépendant et là tout
deviendra possible le dialogue devient
possible des élections pourraient avoir
lieu dans ces conditions qui pourraient
dégager donc les moyens de dalle est
toujours un peu plus loin dans toujours
dans cette dans cette politique de
petits pas progressé de manière à
éventuellement adopter une nouvelle
constitution d'ici quelques années
d'ailleurs je le rappelle qui devrait
avoir lieu d'ici la fin d'année en ces
élections législatives anticipées
merci beaucoup l'ieee benouari pour
toutes ces précisions je rappelle que
vous êtes président du parti algérien
nida el watan merci à vous